a question again to the Shia please this
is just ask you a question don't get
angry don't starting ask your life story
in the comment section this is the fifth
time I believe we're gonna repeat the
same question go ask your Scholars
because I did ask your Scholars they
cannot answer the question how come
is not clear in the Quran if you go to
unclear verses then I will tell you
Allah has warned us and guessed you
Allah said foreign
but the most important according to your
belief they don't even mention even the
concepts of Elvis don't bring us the
verse
please show us you believe we want to
help you to show you Quran does not
support you please again don't ask
yourself in the comment section answer
the question clear verses